um demise
thursday
research conference informatics research
conference
and um as you all know we've continued
this conference during the pandemic at
the same time
um and um who knows maybe the way things
are going with covid we may at some
point get to return to the big theater
um but for now we're going to continue
things remotely um so it gives me um
great pleasure to introduce our speakers
today
this session was
organized by virginia lankees most of
the students know her and faculty as our
career development specialist she is the
expert on the
job market and skills required and so
forth for informatics and she has
recruited
thomas and june from kaiser to
give us a talk today on
um analytical careers and kp insight
northwest so they will talk about their
the nature of their analytical careers
and career paths and marketable skills
they'll give us an overview of kp
insight northwest and the analytics
support that it's provide that it
provides um june song is interim manager
of the health plan operation and
strategy team
of kp insight northwest she has a
master's in statistics from the
university of california davis and a
master's in agricultural economics from
the university of london
tom gant is manager of the utilization
management team of kp insight northwest
tom has a master's in applied statistics
from penn state university
and has completed coursework through
johns hopkins university and building a
data science team so i won't take any
more of their time maybe they can well
it sounds like they'll be telling us
more about
not only what they do but their paths on
how they got there
and so i will let them
take over things from here um i
actually want one other thing um
feel free to type questions in the chat
um once the um
once they're done with their formal
presentation they'll hopefully be some
time for a question and answers and
discussion
and um you can either type in the chat
or unmute yourself um it is the lunch
hour people who are not eating lunch are
welcome to
keep their cameras on
so um i will now turn it over to tom and
june
great thank you bill
i
first want to make sure everybody can
see my screen um i just brought up a
presentation it should say analytical
careers in cape inside northwest
okay great
great so um yeah well first thanks for
the opportunity i know we're both really
excited to have the opportunity to
present to you today
and um i'm gonna i'm gonna jump right in
and since you gave us those
introductions bill i think we can go
ahead and jump right into the to the
first slide we do have con contact
information you'll see this slide at the
end too so if if you need to contact us
feel free to do that
but i'm going to go ahead and jump into
the presentation
so first i'll review today's objectives
uh we want to review
the data analyst consultant role and
what that is and one thing that's
important to understand about that right
off the bat is a data analyst consultant
at one organization could be much
different than a data analyst consultant
at a different organization it can
really mean different things at
different companies
we're going to review the marketable
skills and characteristics when we're
recruiting for these positions different
career paths that you can take once you
once you get into this type of role
and then june's going to give an
overview of our department in the
northwest
and the culture of our department
different career paths within our
department and our focus on career
development
and so the first thing i wanted to do is
give a give a high level definition of
what data analyst consultants do
and
we
our main objective really is to add
value to an organization by leveraging
data to drive decision making to meet
strategic goals so i'm going to unpack
that definition a little bit and i'm
going to start with the strategic goals
so
for us to really have an impact a
measurable impact on on our organization
it's important that we we know the know
what our strategic goals are
and that that our work is supporting
those goals and that's how we can make
sure that we are um having impact so we
always want to make sure when we're
about to embark on an analysis or a new
work that the question that we're
working to answer is of interest of our
to our organization because there are
times where we might have business
partners ask us for things that that
aren't related to our street strategic
goals or maybe um of lesser value we
need to be able to sift through with all
the intakes we get sift through what's
most important and tied to those
strategic goals
and then secondly i would um
talk about how i want to talk about how
our role is really important
in guiding the decision making of the
organization so ultimately we want to
use the data to to guide decision making
and so
those decisions that are being made
again we want to tie into the strategic
goals we want to make sure what we're
doing and the data we're presenting is
something that's going to help us reach
the goals of the organization and so
we spend a lot of time presenting
results and making recommendations
to that end
and then
as our
as the job titles
um
you can kind of get from the job title
that leveraging data is a really big
part of our role so
um most the data when we're leveraging
data most of it is local to our
organization it's stored in database
tables like an oracle table and we're
using different tools to extract that
data
one thing to realize in organizations
there's a wide range of maturity of the
data infrastructure in an organization
so you could have a company that has
huge servers and everything processes
very quickly and they have tons of space
for data or you might have an
organization where things are done in
microsoft excel and microsoft access and
so um it means different things at
different organizations it's important
when you're interviewing for a role like
this to understand
um and a great question to ask is
where's your data sourced how do you
extract your data what data will i have
access to because that'll that'll give
you a good sense of what type of work
you'll be doing what tools you'll be
using
um what data you'll be using and how
what type of analytics overall that
you'll be using
and so
leveraging data also means um
you know we're doing data extraction
we're exploring data um sometimes we do
straight reporting where it's not so
much analysis but there isn't a small
element to the job or depending on where
you're at this can vary too um you're
doing just straight reporting of numbers
a visualization is really big we use
tableau and power bi
and other visualization tools to to help
tell a story and help create nice visual
visual
nice reports for our business partners
um some analysts get into statistical
modeling and machine learning and then
another part of our role and and this
will vary again at organizations is
building data infrastructure
so you might take
you know we have several sources of data
out there you might be combining
different sources into a single table
that allows you to do analysis quicker
or allows you to lay a bi tool like
tableau on top of to create a visual
report
and uh so so a lot of our data is
internal to the organization i did want
to ask a question and feel free to enter
it in the chat or speak out does anybody
have a sense of where else we might get
data from in our in our roles
and i'm not
the way my screen's set up i actually
for some reason i can't see that shot
right now it seems to have somebody
passionate claims
yeah it's it's hard to with webex
unfortunately it's hard to see the chat
i think there's a way to do it but um
but yeah maybe the other of you could
read
okay if someone wants to speak out about
anything that was written that would be
great
yeah i think i heard claims yeah and so
yeah there's yeah there's claims data
there's membership data there's uh from
our electronic medical record there's
data we get from there there's pretty
much endless data sources and i think um
one thing that that we try to keep in
mind too is that we also might get data
from outside our organization so
we might be looking at peer-reviewed
studies from another organization or
university
um because if a question has already
been answered we don't want to answer
the same question again because that can
save us time and we don't always need to
repeat it
and that can happen within our
organization too especially a large
organization like kaiser you may find
yourself as as this turnover and there's
new business partners you get asked the
same question every two years um and so
it's important to make sure that we're
leveraging knowledge outside of kaiser
and knowledge that we've already come up
with within kaiser too
and that can sometimes be challenging
because we don't always have a good way
of of institutionalizing knowledge and
passing
as there's turnover with analysts
passing over knowledge from one analyst
to the next
and then uh i also wanted to highlight
the importance of ultimately we want to
make sure we're adding value to the
organization because
um
in kaiser's case you know we're in in
most cases data analysts are generally
word overhead expense to an organization
so we're not making sales or we're not
providing direct care to patients so we
really need to make sure that we're
proving our value to the organization
so um our the analytics that we provide
needs to be greater than than what we
cost the organization and so we can show
that in many ways and one is through
improved quality so improving patient
outcomes
or it could be decisions leading to
financial savings um
so guiding those decisions like
uh looking at workflows and how how we
can help operational workflows be more
efficient or looking at staff
productivity there's lots of different
ways that we do that depending on the
content area that we're working on
and also a big part of assessing values
um
really to understand the needs of the
operational area you're working with and
that comes through consulting which is a
big part of our role and relationship
building with our business partners and
and as i mentioned earlier just
connecting our work to those strategic
goals and guiding the decision making
and so through that there's a lot of
planning and collaboration that takes
place because we we have more we get
more requests than we can actually do
so uh we we need to make sure that when
we're analyzing the requests that we're
really understanding what what they're
asking so we can assess the value of
them and then make decisions on where
we're going to spend our resources
okay so
i think one thing that's really helpful
when we're doing analytics in the job is
really to understand the types of data
analytic questions that were being asked
and so i have some
and i think that really helps to provide
a useful and actionable
answer to our business partners and so i
have
some different types of questions that
were asked
um
in our roles
and i'm going to go through a scenario
that'll kind of help i think bring to
light what i actually mean by these but
so for example
let's say that we notice that our
readmit rate in the northwest region
which is the percent of patients that
discharge from the hospital how many of
those what percent are just uh
readmitting within 30 days back to the
hospital
so that could be a a question that gets
ants that that might come to light if we
notice our readmit rate is increasing
and there's uh
different ways to look at that and one
type of question
is a descriptive question so what
actually happened so that's like a trend
of readmit rate showing that the readmit
rate did increase over time another way
we might look at that data is um through
exploratory means and that's really
taking the data
and doing some exploratory analysis and
understanding why it happened so we may
find that
that a specific hospital the readmit
rate increased and through exploratory
analysis and maybe they changed some
kind of workflow at that hospital when a
patient is discharging we might learn
that through exploratory analysis
and then inference
question is something similar in that
where those things that we're learning
from our exploratory analysis we might
actually put them to a test to do some
statistical tests to see if we can tie
these variables to the actual outcome of
readmit rate a predictive question would
be
we we might be
taking in a lot of variables and based
off those variables predicting whether a
patient will readmit or not or
developing some kind of risk score
of whether a patient will readmit so we
can make sure that those patients are
getting the follow-up care they need and
directing
limited resources to those patients who
are most going to need it after
discharging from the hospital
and then a causal question would be well
what happened if what happens if we
change this workflow when a patient is
discharging from the hospital or we
change this this type of care that
they're receiving their post-discharge
care what will happen
to to their
eventual um care will they end up
readmitting or not so that could be a
causal question and then the mechanistic
question
gets more into why did it actually
happen so we saw an increasing trait in
our readmit rate what actually caused
that so
um and are we able to tie it to that so
it gets more specific around well in our
in our
discharge procedures the ner the nurse
now does this rather than this and we
then this is why we're seeing the
patients are readmitting more to the
hospital so
that's just an example of the different
types of questions
um that we might
answer within that scenario
and i think one thing that's important
is to to um
understand whether the question can
actually be answered or not because
sometimes we might be asked the question
where we can't actually answer it the
data doesn't support it and an example
of that is
um
operationally they might put in a new
initiative maybe it's a new care group
around certain patients with diabetes or
something like that and they come back
to us and ask well did this care group
have an impact did it improve the health
of the patient did it reduce their
hospital utilization
and many times um
we might this study when the care group
was set up it wasn't set up in a way
that we can capture the data and make a
valid study of whether it actually made
an improvement and i think that's where
like consulting and relationship
building with our business partners
really comes into play because we want
to
when those studies are being built um we
want to be involved early on in the
process so we can make sure um when
those initiatives are being built that
that they're being built in a way that
they're capturing data that we'll be
able to make an analysis after and help
them determine the success of the
program because a lot of the times
operational decisions will just move
forward without analytics involved and
then at the end they want to know the
answer of whether it was successful or
not
where we really want to build those
relationships and get involved earlier
in the process so we can provide some
consulting and guidance of the rollout
of the initiative
and then uh i did want to spend a little
bit on time on how
the
data analysts fit within an organization
because this will be really important if
you're pursuing a career in data
analytics to understand
uh where the position sits in the
organization so when you're interviewing
for a position like this you would want
to know
is is this a position that's embedded on
an operational team so
um if it's a like a data analyst in
imaging would you be sitting with the
imaging team the operational imaging
team or is that position going to sit on
a centralized analytics team because it
does make a difference
in what your your role will be like for
example
if you're on an operational team it'll
be much easier to understand the
business that's an advantage because
you'll really be very in close proximity
with those who are doing imaging every
day and those who are who you're
answering analytical questions for
um
and it also facilitates relationship
building with the customers who you're
ultimately providing the data for and i
think it it opens your eyes to
non-analytical career path options also
because there's there's a lot of career
paths out there in an organization
and um you
you will have more exposure to actual
the business side of things when you sit
on an operational team
if you're on a centralized analytics
team
there's many advantages to that as well
there's more standard analytical
practices so you're using best practices
more you can leverage each other's work
there's a lot a lot of efficiencies that
can be gained when you're when you're
learning about doing data analytics
because you're sitting around other
analysts and learning from each other
there's also support for resourcing work
so if you have a lot to do
or if one analyst has a lot to do and
one doesn't have as much at any given
time the work can be spread more about
the or uh throughout the
team better where that wouldn't take
place in a decentralized model it also
uh
promotes collaboration among the
analysts and there's uh if you're on a
centralized analytics team there's more
analytical career path options so i
don't think there's really a
one-size-fits-all or a best
best uh
solution i think it really depends on
the organization
the size of the organization and the
complexity of data sources i think one
ideal that it should often be looked at
is that data analysts sit in an
analytics department but there's a real
concerted effort that there's dedicated
teams that work really to build
relationships and learn
different um really learn the business
of external groups so
and that really means
whether you're wherever you're embedded
it's really that engagement with your
customers is extremely important
okay so the next slide i wanted to speak
to some of the skill sets and
characteristics that we look for when
we're recruiting
um for these types of positions so it is
helpful to have some kind of programming
skills like sql or python r or another
um some kind of programming background
quant quantitative skills like or
quantitative background statistics or
math or or have math or statistics or
some quantitative
skill within the major that that your or
your background
um bi visualization tools we use that
battle those a lot tableau and power bi
um i think it's really important to
just have an attitude where you're not
not intimidated by new tools and or
complex databases because there's a lot
of complexity and there's a lot of
learning that goes on and we're
continually bringing in new tools so
real openness to learning new tools and
then strong written communication is is
important as well
because we're telling stories with the
data not just orally but often times
through written presentations
soft skills business ackman is is
important in really wanting to learn the
content area that you're providing
analytics for and i've mentioned
consulting before um earlier
being a strong communicator and
intellectually curious is a big one i
think in analytics because we we really
are we're digging through data and we're
we're trying to find insights so i would
really highlight that one um being
proactive a problem solver
and a strong collaborator we learn a lot
from each other um in our department and
we have a lot of peer training and
really working with others that can
really um
develop excuse me develop a lot and gain
skills
and i would say um one thing i want to
highlight though these
these that i listed it really depends on
the level of position um for
more entry-level positions we wouldn't
really be requiring someone to know all
these or you know um just to show that
they had the aptitude in the will to to
want to learn these and there's also a
difference between a generalist versus
specialist generally um
a lot of our analysts
we we look for are strong or have
strengths in all these areas but we do
have specialists as well that can be
really helpful like we have some some of
our analysts are really strong
technically um but don't enjoy the
consulting side as much and and there's
a place
in our team for those uh people as well
and then i did want to talk spend some
time talking about careers related to
data analytics and so as i mentioned
earlier the mapping of of what you
actually do to position names will vary
a lot by organizations so
what a position actually does in an
organization is
is
you might not be able to tell that from
the actual job description and so it is
important when interviewing to really
try to understand um
what the role is beyond that initial job
description and job title but some of
the ones that i'd like to go through are
the data analytics consultant manager
and that's what june and i are and so
our role is really to understand the
needs of the organization
um resource projects
appropriately
plan plan ahead and ensure the
appropriate level of collaboration is
occurring
um developing develop new team members
or continually developing our team team
members
uh we we spend time um
recruiting new analysts and some of the
skills and characteristics uh for that
position is a knowledge and the software
and tools being used
understanding the roles and not just the
data analysts but what others do like a
data engineer or data scientists
and um as i mentioned earlier it's
important that we we
are
adaptive
focusing on appropriate problems
um and we also need to be able to
provide analytical support when
necessary because um if we're resource
constrained a lot of times we'll have to
dig in and do some analytics as well
and um and i think being able to deliver
results whether they're positive or
disappointing results in a
solution-oriented positive manner a lot
of times you know there might be a
business partner who has an initiative
and they're really tied to the success
of that initiative and it can be
challenging you know if you do run a
study on it and you're showing it's not
having the intended impact but being
able to you know deliver those results
that that's what the data is showing but
um
as i mentioned in a positive manner and
and just being supportive of a team
being a being a people person and really
um meeting regularly with our team
members understanding their needs and
looking out for development
opportunities and opportunities that
they can take advantage of to progress
their careers
and then the next one is a data
analytics consultant lead
and they um
it's similar to data analyst but it they
take a leading role and they're very
adept with their technical skills and
their consulting skills and but they
don't want to be a people manager so so
it's a path for those who don't want to
be a people manager within the analytics
career but they can they can lead from
more of the the peer analytics
perspective and less of an hr
perspective
um the next one is a data engineer so a
data engineer
they really will be focusing on building
infrastructure
purchasing equipment or software and
building and managed databases and
data storage and use and implementing
production tools and production tools
with those are
as data analysts might build reports or
build analyses some of those will be
repeatable or and we'll want to repeat
those every week or every day or every
month they help us
put those into production so we can
automate them and not have to do
anything manually once those are built
and usually a data engineer will have
more of a computer science i.t
background
person versus a data analyst and then
there's other roles
um
operational roles where
you i had mentioned earlier
one of the advantages of being embedded
in an operational team is it'll open up
your eyes to a lot of different
potential operational roles if you find
that you don't want to do analytics long
term
another one is a business analysts
business analysts are would be an
analyst that would probably be more
likely to sit in an operational team
versus an embedded analytics team they
they would do um
i would say they're similar to data
analysts and that but probably a little
less technical and less getting into the
data but more interpreting the data and
and
relaying the data to two operational
partners who are going to be using it
but um as i mentioned earlier these
roles are all um can can be a crossover
and though this
in our organization we do a little bit
of every role really listed here um as a
data analyst
and then the last one i wanted to speak
to is a data scientist and we hear about
this a lot we know this is a really uh
career that's really growing right now
and it's kind of a hot career
um and so i wanted to spend a little
time on this does anybody or did if
anybody wants to put in the chat what
they think a data scientist does that
would be great i think it means
different things to different people
but um
i'm gonna i'm gonna jump into the next
slide which does review that a little
bit and it talks about the difference
between data science versus data
analytics so i guess again i would say
it's not a clear distinction it is
really organization dependent
but um and what are common to both is
consulting and communication
math and statistics
data visualization
programming and statistical programming
and and content knowledge understanding
your business i think when we think of
data science where it's uh it's a little
more specialized in that you're getting
more into machine learning um you're
using python and r to build models more
more
versus a statistical model where um the
relationship between the variables and
the outcome might be more obvious
in a black box model and machine
learning it's it's doing a lot more
processing and they're more they're the
relationships between the the dependent
and independent or the independent
variable and your dependent variable or
outcomes aren't as obvious but um so
it's a much more
much more programming related field and
i would say um
again though we as data analytics and
depending on how comfortable someone is
we we delve into the data science world
too
um and you could have a data science
role out there that you apply for and
you may find that it's
more you're just doing straight
reporting so i i guess i would want to
summarize up when you when you look at
your different roles and understand your
need understand your interests and make
sure you're asking questions during the
interview that's
so you can get the information you need
to make sure that the role will align to
your interests
and
so that was my part of the presentation
i'm going to hand it off to june and
move to the next slide here
thank you tom so tom talked about like
in general how the
analytical careers what what are the
different roles involved i'm gonna dive
in
deeper into
specifically to our department the
department tom and i work in
it's called kb insight northwest
our mission for
our department is to provide kaiser
northwest region with business
intelligence and analytics
that helps them to lead the market in
high quality and affordable healthcare
to our members
um
we have about like 35 people in our
department it's a really strong
analytical team
that supports the region
health plan operations
and we have a separate team like in the
region for the perm side but we our team
specifically supports the health plan
entity
we do oversee
how our region collects and organize and
utilize different informations we take
the region's diverse data and transform
it into actionable information to our
business partner try to improve their
decision making and goal setting
we also like report up through the
finance department
uh we work closely with our business
partner in
different areas that you will see later
probably next slides um
what are the specific areas for health
plan and care delivery settings within
kpinsight at kp northwest
as a department we do value
honesty and integrity
collaboration and innovation and we also
not forgetting fun because it is
actually a fun
um
career path if you're really
interested in digging into like the data
and bring some insight to our business
partners
um so next slides
so here's um
within our t within our department we
have about like six teams and
we have a population health team that
focus on quality and patient safety
and service and care experiences
population health definitely and also
we have a
person dedicated to
occupational health
um we also do like employer group
reporting through that team
um
the other team health plan operation and
strategy that's my team and we do
support the health plan services and
administration part um
helping with regional call center
and ambulatory care that involves
message management and
primary care specialty care staffing
claims and outside medical costs those
type of thing and as well as external
reporting that includes
some regulatory requirement for apac
apcd those are au pair alkaline data
to fulfill the state requirement
the finance team and dental team that
covers
financial report
labor reporting as well supply chain
we have a person dotted line to
hr
analytics
they also support dental operations
and kaiser actually in the northwest
region where the only region has dental
operation
uh they also support action alright
benchmarking as well
and in tom's team the the utilization
management
team they cover um
eddy like pdr those hospital metrics and
also
hospital utilization and
inpatient transitions imaging and
lab within the hospital team that covers
hospital operations
hospital quality skilled nursing
facilities home health
and continuing care service
we have a pharmacy team that's thought
the line to us they initially resided
within our team but then later on
reports to pharmacy
uh business just like what tom mentioned
they reside in in the within the
business so that they can serve their
business better
they cover outpatient pharmacy inpatient
pharmacy
clinical administered medications
oncology pharmacy
and clinical pharmacy service
so through all those
areas that we support we develop and
distribute a very like wide range of
reports and dashboards
um
usually a report may start out as an
exploratory analysis that evolves into a
regular
monitoring tools
may be defined by the operational and
stress strategic goals of the
organization or maybe
dictated by regulatory requirements
eventually the reports will be fully
augmented and
then they will be transitioned to the
kpinsight production support team
after certain business criteria and
technical criteria met
with some much of the integrated kaiser
permanente world available in some of
some form of structured electronic data
we have
there's a huge opportunity for using
more advanced analytical techniques to
discover more new patterns and
relationships and to help predict how
our system and our patient
populations are likely to act in the
future
so
we
for that on that topic we we do have
so far developed a range of models
including predictive risk scores
multivariate exp exploratory analysis
forecasts simulations and text mining
models
um
we continue to invest time and resource
in developing more like
[Music]
our endless experience and expertise in
this very important analytical capacity
next
so as a department um
we used to have a we're actually in a
phase transitioning into a more
consulting culture rather than
uh
providing data report
those type of like surface level
reporting
um
the reason for that is the old model
that we had
we
we just basically meeting the
requirements or requests from our
business partner whatever they need
um not so much deeper into like what
exactly
is involved
um
we're just basically fulfilling a
request in a way and that doesn't
really bring much insight into the
business partner and they don't know
what that what data we have we don't
know what exactly they trying to resolve
so a lot of a report after
uh developing that type of report is not
being used
effectively
um
so with that like after a few years now
we're actually trying to transition into
a
whole department-wide culture of
consulting rather than
service as a helping hand
so the
department culture in a way that helps
us to
function as a role of consulting and
collaborating and to soft partnership
with our business partner
our analysts are
key members of the care delivery and
operational teams they support so we
wanted to be able to guide our business
partner in developing hypotheses to
address their care delivery and business
questions
and in helping identify
specific information and analysis needed
to test their ideas
even evaluating some of the programs
they have
to
bring trying to refine their process or
just bring more efficiency
into their
work
so in in collaboration with our business
partner we
often design metrics and reports and
dashboards that help them
effectively monitoring operational
processes and outcome
so
with the consulting model we
these are the benefits uh we're trying
to with the consolidate the benefit for
further organization as a whole is on
the right side the lighter blue colored
so
this
involves
[Music]
this involves like focusing on high
impact work and drive changes
for the organization and improve
organization effectiveness and have
buy-ins and
from the business partner and saving
cost
and to help us to remain competitive in
the market
in the darker blue circle these are the
benefits for
individual analysts and so as analysts
we can get out of the low value work
we get empowerment through
being a good consultant to our business
partner and bring insight
we also
have a supportive and accountability
from our peer
[Music]
and
peer-to-peer learning as well and we do
have
influence and
bring market value for our business
partner
next slides
so within our department we have this
endless role that tom mentioned earlier
is the formal title is called data
reporting and analytic consultant we
have
five levels
uh level five is the lead so
with your experience and
technical backgrounds or consulting
skill
level then you can move up the career
ladder here we do recruit those analysts
through either internships or
external recruiting or sometimes from
other kb department as well when
there's a lot of flexibility for us to
move around within kb
um when your interests switch from one
area to another
uh even within our department we can
switch teams
and within like across from department
there's a wide range of different
interests as well like that's
um very flexible for people move around
within the organization
we also have other rules um that tom
mentioned a little bit
you can go to management eventually or
we have project management
to support all different projects and
admin staff as well
next slide
um
in terms of uh
career development within our department
we have a
in-house
career like
trainings within the organization kaiser
does provides a lot of trainings
that includes a lot of wide range of
different skills including soft skills
and technical skills
although
within organization
we don't have a lot of specific
technical skills that we use that have
training programs within kaiser like for
example different tools
um
different
statistical
analysis those we don't have in kaiser
but within our department we have annual
budgeted
dedicated budget for training
for analysts
that you can either attend
technical classes or conferences
we also started to have peer-led
training and development programs within
ourselves
um the consulting program that culture
that we i mentioned earlier that it's
actually come from
within our department we organized a
consulting program training which
is a very extensive
consulting
skill training program that lasts six
months
the goal is to
help
analysts to develop that
consulting skill um on an ongoing basis
not just a taking a class and then be
done with it and that skill needs
refined over time and
different for different projects and
scenarios
we also have cross team and crossroads
collaboration that open time we work
with our perm side
partners of the analytical team
to collaborate on because oftentimes
health also across my sperm site and
looking at the doctor information and
physician clinician
information as well and same
vice versa they also wanted to see the
health plan side so we do have a lot of
collaboration on that and also
collaborate with our original strategic
implementation office to bring in
high
high level like priority projects to to
our team so that we can
make impact to our original
critical decisions
within kaiser we also have stretch
projects and that you can talk to
manager and
work on a project that probably totally
different from analytical projects and
that's something if people interested
they have opportunity to develop their
either project management skills or
other skills that
the stretch projects can bring
and we have uh
established a mentoring system
and networking system as well if you
need a mentor there's a platform that
you can sign up and ask for a mentor
and request for mentorship as well
and overall we have a very supportive
department culture and you probably can
see that
through
the talk we have mentioned
next slide
so this one is just a brain overall um
to see like how different skills fitting
together and
as a analytic consultant it's really a
mixed bag of different skills
and we as a tom mentioned technical
skill definitely is a
very basic foundation skills that to
begin with as an analyst
and that involves
whatever specific technical skill that
that fits your discipline for us as an
analyst we
the etl skills data science science
skills
um
programming skills statistic modeling
those are all like technical skills
that's really valuable
and then interpersonal skills are
crucial as well
this involves being authentic and being
real true to yourself
and have relations
know how to build relationships
and
listening skills is also not a huge
skill to have
dealing with conflicts and handling
resistance from our business partner or
your customers
um managing bp
business partner
expectations
uh leadership style that's
like based on people and those are very
good personal interpersonal skills to
have
and under last box those consulting
skills
um
over time they become really valuable to
be able to acquire those skills
to be able to do contracting or
negotiating with our business partner
because oftentimes they have their idea
but it may not be the ideal
[Music]
plan for them
and
so be able to also
ask for resources if you need their help
that's very critical as well
and so throughout different consulting
phases there are different skills
involved and with the combination of the
technical skill interpersonal skill and
consulting skill these are
using wisely and appropriately this can
help us to make impact and drive changes
i think that's probably is the
the last slide and
tom you can feel free to bring the last
slide the contact information if people
need it
so with that i'll leave some time for
questions and answer
your questions
great thank you that's excellent talk
it's um very interesting to hear
both what your
organization does and also
your your own journeys and and the
skills um maybe you could stop um
sharing the slides that way i think you
both would be able to see the chat there
are a few
um questions in there
um
including one for me on you were listing
um the various tools
um there's a lot of interest and
enthusiasm uh in these quarters here for
some of the visual programming machine
learning tools like orange and rapid
rapidminer
do you see roles for those in
your shop
currently
those tools we don't have
like an infrastructure really to support
i would say our machine learning that
takes place is more within using python
um that would be our primary tool that
we're doing those types of models in
okay
and
yeah
we do have a sandbox that's for
experiencing different tools um
we have sparks and
those type of things so currently like
tom said the orange and the other two
was not in our department
yet but
you never know like there might be
future opportunities to learn that
sure then there's another question from
changda one of our quantum conformatics
fellows
do you work with individual clinicians
to address specific patient care
questions such as is there significant
difference in quality metrics with my
practice compared to my colleagues or do
you primarily work with administration
there are um north so so the other
analytics group um one of the other
analytics groups in the northwest region
is called
northwest perm analytics and so they
work for northwest permanente which is
the actual technically a separate
company and that's the doctors basically
and we worked really closely with them
um
they would be doing more that analytics
group would be do more
more of the comparison among doctors in
terms of
metrics when comparing among doctors but
we
are our organization the health plan
side of things which is the hospitals
and the nurses we would do be doing some
of that work when looking at nurses or
different other clinical staff that
aren't doctors
right and then there i don't know how
well you can see the chat now but then
there is a question any prerequisites
like specific epic certifications to
apply
i assume that's at the epic ehr
certifications that some people have
yeah we do
work with
using the epic data a lot at the backend
we call it clarity so if you know epic
it's definitely a
plus
because sometimes we do have to go into
patient
member charts to
get around and trying to see where that
data in the back end is so
um
certification is not required but if you
have that skill that's definitely a plus
yeah yeah as jun said we use we use epic
a lot um to validate data and to
understand um how it's entering the
front end system and yeah some analysts
who are really interested in this or
really work closely in the area um can
also get a certification if they'd like
to it's not very common but we do have
analysts who are working very closely in
the different modules
of epic
and we do do we do
contract with epic they sometimes will
come in and do training there's
trainings we take through epic as well
any other
questions from the audience either
type in the chat or
unmute yourselves
okay well um uh again thank you uh very
much for um
um coming to speak to us and uh it's
interesting to hear what um an
organization like kaiser is doing in
this space
we have your contact information and and
we have a connection
through virginia
and
hopefully there might be some
opportunities for some of our students
so i want to thank everyone
for attending today
and
we will meet again next week we have
another external speaker
who some of you may know or heard of dr
betsy toll and she will be speaking to
us next week so have a good day everyone
see you all later bye-bye
thank you thank you thank you everyone
bye
you